when Peter Minuit bought Manhattan Island
a wilderness of forest and stream from the
Indians for $24 worth of trade goods in 1626 the
enterprising Dutchman struck a good bargain for
three centuries later the investment had increased
in value 400 million times and viewed from the
moon that is safe would appear as a great fungus
growth that had slowly spread and consumed the
wilderness but we're getting ahead of our story
by 1660 the thriving Dutch settlement of New
Amsterdam had begun to take definite shape at the
lower tip of the island the city's requirements
were few and simple a stockade and poured as
protection against hostile Indians storehouses for
food in the goods of the West India Company houses
for settlers a landing place and a recreation
center the Bowling Green governor Peter Stuyvesant
great house was the most imposing structure in the
settlement and stood where the custom house now
is today the needs of that locality are vastly
different and the city has adapted itself to the
change demands only the bowling-green has left its
trace by 1750 the wilderness had receded Upper
Manhattan had become almost a suburb but it was
a long journey by coach to the Bluebell Tavern
at Broadway and 180 first Street now it is a
matter of minutes for the teeming millions who
daily come to the cities business centers over
thousands of miles of Transport arteries but far
below the earth by land and water New York by 1850
had become one of the world's greatest seaports
sailing ships from every corner of the globe
brought their cargoes to the metropolis of the
new world south street was a wilderness of spars
and rigging serving the needs of sailor and ship
today the shipping center has moved huge ocean
leviathans discharged their passengers and freight
on the great piers that line the north river
as we have seen the city is a living growing
thing continually changing and adapting itself
to new conditions then what of the future change
in all probability will be even greater than in
the past let you Ferris the artist and architect
give us his vision of the city of the future of
course no one can clearly foresee the city
of the future but the appearance in any city
of any period of history is a direct outcome of
the social economic and technological conditions
then existing take for example the city of
today a vast conglomeration of skyscrapers
and slums owners building whatever tenement or
tower they please on their own plots here is
the architectural record of an economic order of
lace a fair and rugged individualism if we are to
abandon this for some new order based on broad
scale long-term planning it also will produce
an architecture all its own cities of the future
would be laid out according to master plans their
streets and buildings no longer haphazard but
harmoniously related the skyscraper in itself
a useful form would still appear but only
an isolated predetermined points in the city
plan structural ingenuity would of course go on
producing unusual forms perhaps suspension bridge
apartment houses these would surely provide wide
vistas for the bridge dwellers and perhaps gratify
the very human desire for novelty and romance
but City planning would be quite realistic as
to our future streets they must be broad avenues
providing speed and ease of movement with light
and pure air for abutting buildings perhaps the
master stroke of planning would be to segregate
on one hand coordinated to automatic industrial
centers all needed goods and distributing them
in abundance while far removed and entirely
outside the atmosphere of the machine would
rise new centers of leisure around which we would
live fully participating in the sports the arts
the sciences in all the activities which make life
worth living those celestial astronomers should
there be any they glimpse in our future cities
an environment fully encouraging to human values
an environment already made feasible by modern
science and awaiting only a modernized economics
in bus flivver or proud rolls-royce you
may follow the seahorse to Jones Beach
State Park New York's amazing 3,000 acres
seaside playground parking spaces provided
for twenty three thousand cars a mile
long boardwalk with cafeterias dining
rooms and tea terraces for every
purse cleanliness is the watchword
fringed by the Atlantic Ocean on one side
and the quiet Bay waters on the other the
beach is an ideal refuge from the
heat and noise of the nearby city
the property of the state for
the people's free enjoyment
you
a sunlit saltwater pool is free to less
venturesome bathers also a special one
for children where free swimming instruction is
given 1,200 were taught to swim here in 1934 if
you go in for this sort of thing here it is
every afternoon at 3:00 completely free of
the noisy Midway amusements found in most
seaside parks healthful out-of-door games
are provided for children and grown-ups alike
many of them free playgrounds under competent
Supervisors and a sand pile 5 miles long make
it a veritable paradise for children of all ages
Zack's Bay is ideal for small boat in
for no racing if you tire of clouds and
organized amusement just wander up
the beach which stretches straight
and unspoiled for 17 miles Sun air and
sea free to everyone who will take the
trouble to seek them a social achievement
of tremendous importance here is democracy
at its best a milestone on the path
our forefathers chose a reality which
gives a glimpse of the golden promise and
boundless hope of our America of tomorrow